[Music]
so this is this is a really this is a
great talk we we have for you tonight
let me ask how many before before we
started before before the interval
existed is the interval we used to do
our seminars about long-term thinking
pretty much always here at Fort Mason
who attended anyone here raise your
hands if you attended a Salt talk here
at Fort Mason how many there we go
and and in the very beginning in 2003
2004 the first year of salt talks
actually most of them were in in this
building what's now I guess gallery 308
it's called now so in a smaller room at
the end of this building and it was a
much simpler time in in in long now's
world you would see Stuart brand and
Danny Hillis doing their own tech pretty
much we had we had amazing speakers
still but it was a single camera at the
bathroom you can see these videos on
YouTube and and it's kind of cool
because not only is it show our rather
humble beginnings and make you
appreciate the multi-camera
professionally edited shoots that we
have for our videos today now if it now
available on iOS but but it also lets us
locate exactly when at least
approximately tonight's speaker came
into our orbit as it were as he sits
like a Mystery Science Theater profile
through the entirety of the talk with I
believe been sitting next to you on this
and several other talks so we we know
he's he's been around he's he's Mike is
has had a remarkable career as you'll
hear tonight that has tracked rather
perfectly with this world of networked
computers that has gone from net to web
to ubiquity
and he is the perfect person to talk to
us about it and now he sees a park and
I'm excited to say that this is actually
the first of kind of a series within our
series where we're where Mike's gonna
help me curate folks researchers from
Park coming up on a regular basis to
tell us a bit more here at the interval
about what they're working on so without
any further ado let's have a big round
of applause for mr. Mike clean off skate
thanks Mike it's it's a great pleasure
to be here so thank you very much so
today what I want to do is I want to
look at how our relationship to the
world changes when we're surrounded by
devices by things that anticipate our
needs and act on them so this means that
it sits at the intersection of several
different things it's just the intersect
intersection of what's now called the
Internet of Things what's called a user
experience design and machine learning
and although people have dealt with some
subset of those things in the past um I
don't think they've ever quite come
together the way they are right now or
kind of with the current enthusiasm as
you'll see um and and I want to be clear
up front so I am neither a fan of nor a
critic of these technologies I think
that they're actually too complex to be
reduced in that way and that what we
need to do is you know the my message
here is that what we need to do is to
maximize their positive impact by
actively engaging with them and that's
what this talk is trying to essentially
start as a discussion so what I'm going
to do today is I'm going to talk in kind
of several parts and and some of it will
get nerdy so it starts with an overview
of how I think the Internet of Things
that inner things devices you know
physical things that are electronic
these days they're actually components
of services rather than being
self-contained experiences like a hammer
and how predictive machine learning
predictive behavior and Able's key
components of those services and then
since this is along now what I want to
do is I want to finish
by exploring some speculative ideas
about what kind of impact they're gonna
have on us you know as individuals and
as a society so at its core in this talk
um the idea is that everything is going
to be connected to the Internet
everything is going to be connected
whether we want it or not and those
things we'll all be trying to predict
our immediate future and that this is
going to fundamentally change our
relationship to the world so a couple of
caveats before I really get into this my
current work on his field focuses almost
exclusively on the consumer enter of
things there are a lot of things in this
space around medicine around industry
that are also a big fields that's not
work that I'm doing right now so most of
my examples are are from the consumer
side I also want to point out that few
of the issues that I raised are new you
know you can search for the terms know
if you look for Internet of Things in
machine learning they're kind of
relatively recently popular they're hot
right now but the ideas have been
discussed for decades if you search for
ubiquitous computing or ambient
intelligence or pervasive computing
you'll see a lot of great thought in
that space in the last twenty five years
and if you're really ambitious you can
start looking into the artificial
intelligence and cybernetics stuff from
the 50s and 60s and you'll be really
surprised by the prescience of the
people who are working at that time when
the entire world's compute power it was
less than what you have in your key fob
so there are a lot of ideas here and I'm
gonna skip through a lot of different
things and I'll almost certainly under
explain some things and for that I
apologize in advance but my goal here is
to give you a general sense of how the
dots fit together rather than talking
about any single dot so finally most of
my slides don't have words on them all
the words are right here so what I'll do
is I'll make the complete deck with the
transcript available as soon as I'm done
so let me give you a very quick
background about Who I am not
necessarily why I'm here but Who I am so
I'm a user experience designer I was one
of the first professional web designers
in the early 90s this is the navigation
for a hotsauce shopping site
I designed 22 years ago so thank you oh
yes
there's someone else who's worked on
that very product and I bet you still
have a closet full of this stuff and you
don't ever use it anyway
so I've also worked on a user experience
design of a lot of consumer electronics
products from companies you've heard of
and I can't tell you about and now let
me give you a quick aside for those who
don't know what user experience design
is so user experience design is not
graphic design it's an interface design
it's not organic so it's not an
industrial design it's not a product
design it includes aspects of all of
those disciplines UX design from my
definition is a humanistic
problem-solving approach that brings
together the needs of people and
businesses to create or organizations
but really generally businesses to
create technological products that are
valuable to both groups it's actually
much more about process than it is about
making things look good so the field is
about twenty years old I've been in it
for about that time and this is what it
looked like about 15 years ago today
it's a little more complex it's all more
complex but it's basically still the
same thing it's basically a humanistic
approach to thinking about technology so
I wrote a couple of books about it so
the ones on the ends if my you know I
wrote a couple books based on my
experience as a designer the one on the
left is a cookbook of user research
methods the one on the right
describes that I think are some of the
core concerns when designing and
networked computational devices the one
in them in the middle is actually by my
wife so essentially I wanted to put here
both to plug it because it's the newest
one and also to say that it's a family
business and we talk about this a lot
and so I'm really influenced by her so I
started a couple of companies the first
on the left was primarily focused on the
web
it was probably most famous for coining
the term blog although I was not
involved in that the the one on the
right I got a pretty deep into
developing hardware today I worked for
part the famous research lab that
brought you the personal computer
object-oriented software the tablet
computer the laser printer and I'm as a
principle in its innovation Services
Group and let me plug that for a second
we what we do and those of you out there
who work for large companies can hire us
we help companies reduce the risk of
adopting novel technologies using a mix
of social research design and business
strategy there are several people from
our group in this room I can introduce
you they can give you more pitch okay so
part one of the things about this was
way before my time I was explaining to
somebody that you know this was done
when I was three years old so I was not
here when this happened
so Park also started thinking about what
we call the inner of things way before
other companies so in 1971 dick Shoop
who's a early researcher wrote that
eventually processors would be
essentially as common and as invisible
as electric motors so essentially what
he was saying is that eventually like
this is 1971 he's essentially saying the
computers which at that point where the
size of a building are going to be as
boring as an electric motor it's they're
going to be in everything so by the late
1980s also at Parc Mark Weiser coined
the term ubiquitous computing to
describe that exact phenomenon to talk
about when computers are going to
surpass a number of people using them
which in the 80s was almost unthinkable
that was the personal computer business
had already started was kind of
unthinkable so this chart from about 20
years ago maybe more than that for about
20 years ago you can see was made in
Microsoft Paint
right so it's on this and in this chart
he predicted that there would be there's
crossover there would happen around 2005
2006 when the number of computers would
surpass the number of people so
unfortunately mark did not actually live
to see this he died like around here but
what happened here the iPhone launched
that's a so he was essentially exactly
right about that and we today live in
the world that he envisioned about 30
years ago so essentially what we now see
as a novel phenomenon a phenomenon has
actually been foreseen by people in the
industry for
decades the question has not been about
what is going to happen but how we're
going to get there and when we're going
to get there so unfortunately the
ubiquitous computing vision doesn't
happen perfectly all at once so we've
actually just started to see the
transition to this ubiquitous computing
world and as such we're seeing a lot of
bad ideas about the Internet of Things
is and isn't essentially everything that
can be connected to the Internet right
now is a lot of things that cause a lot
of things that shouldn't be there
actually so many bad ideas there their
entire tumblers that are dedicated to it
so here's one it's called we put a chip
in it it was a dumb thing we put a chip
in it that's a smart thing and so you
know in my favorite one which I hear
people laughing is a [ __ ] yeah internet
fridge which is just about mocking
internet for a refrigerator ideas so and
it's actually been going for years and
it's still going it's amazing anyway um
so most of these things are bad ideas
you know why are they bad ideas why are
we laughing because apart from the fact
that it's funny because simply
connecting stuff to the Internet does
not actually produce value for people
you know simple connectivity you know it
really helps when you're trying to
maximize the efficiency of a fixed
process like in a business but that's
actually not a problem that most people
have in their houses now we've been able
to simply connect various devices to the
computer so you see since you could take
your Tandy color computer in 1983 it
turned lights off and on with it you
over x10 you know the problem is is that
that wasn't a good idea then and it's
not a good idea now um if you replace
the Tandy with an iPhone and you replace
the lamp with a washing machine you know
this story you see it at CES every year
or you know my favorite is that you you
know if you're placed with an egg carton
you still have the same problem and it's
the user experience problem and the user
experience problem it's that people
you're essentially making people connect
all the dots to coordinate between all
these different devices that are smart
and to interpret the meaning of what all
the sensors are doing to create value
for themselves you know for many just
simple telemetry projects
products there's so little efficiency to
be had in that like you got to take out
your phone you got a tap on the things
you gotta take launched there's so
little efficiency to be had it's just
not worth it what's worse is that you're
actually creating extra cognitive load
which is exactly the opposite of what
the thing is promising you know people
essentially end up feeling intensely
disappointed because maybe even betrayed
because they're actually getting less
out of it than they were promised you're
promised our labor-saving device and I
got a laborer creating device so that
effectively makes most such products
worse than useless because they're
actually you know they're negatively
useless
so the that promise gap at least for me
is what distinguishes what we would call
a gadget from tool and that's why this
head carton is funny and that is why
poor P the company that made it filed
for bankruptcy after burning through a
couple hundred million dollars worth of
venture funding so how do you create a
tool that reduces cognitive load instead
of creating it that exchanges people's
precious precious time for real value so
one approach the one that I advocate the
one that I like the one that we're
actually a park deeply embedded in is to
couple cloud-based services so
essentially things that are up in the
things that look like internet services
with predictive machine learning models
to anticipate what is going to maximize
the chances of a desirable outcome for
the users how do you make things better
for people without making them do extra
work now let me unpack some of this
stuff a little bit and let me talk start
by talking about what I mean by services
so I'm thinking about hardware devices
essentially physical representatives of
these cloud services but which makes
them actually very different than
traditional consumer electronics so
historically a company made an
electronic product you know say a
turntable and then they found people who
would sell it for them then they
advertised it heavily and people bought
them and that was the end of their
relationship with it with that customer
until they were able to convince that
person to buy another one so that is the
entire value of that relationship
to be packaged to us in the device
itself which is you know my pet theory
is that that's why they used to put like
heavy metal plates and consumer
electronics so they would feel like you
were getting more value out of them with
the Internet of Things the sale of the
device it's actually just the beginning
of the relationship it's not the end of
the relationship it's the beginning of
the relationship and the physical thing
actually holds almost no value for
either the consumer or the manufacturer
value now shifts to services and the
devices but the devices the software
applications and you know the websites
the apps that are used to access it I
call those things avatars their physical
representatives of I think that's up in
the clouds right so I also want to steal
back from the VR people it was totally
wrong so anyway um so a camera becomes a
really good appliance for taking photos
for Instagram a TV becomes a really nice
way to display Instagram photos that you
don't have to log into every time you
can show people at a party a phone
becomes a really convenient way both to
take photos and to check your friends
photos photo streams or Kanye's when
you're on the road hardware the physical
things in this situation becomes
simultaneously more specialized and
devalued as people see through each
device to the service it represents
people don't care about the device they
care about the service
the avatars exist in order to get better
value out of the service Amazon really
gets this so you know here's a telling
older ad from Amazon for the Kindle what
it's saying is look use whatever device
you want we don't care as long as you
stay loyal to our service you can buy
one of our specialized devices that we
lose money on every time on purpose
because the value is in this service but
you can use some other way to access our
services and we won't have to lose money
on that on the device when fire was
launched and it was originally Kindle
Fire now you know you have fire stick
and fire phone you know our IP not
really an IP but anyway when when those
of you who go to of those would get that
joke anyway
so when when fire was released Bezos
even called it a service it is not Adam
there's not a thing it is a service
Amazon - is a service that's enabled by
dedicated device so this is a real thing
so you can buy a washing machine from
whirlpool or GE that will reorder its
own supplies it will reorder its own its
own tied when it's running out out of
tide will reorder its own bleach run
Sarang please you can buy this today
this is enabled by amazon's - service
and the reason that amazon made this is
so that they wouldn't have to make these
devices you know shipping all that metal
it's really expensive why should we
making it why shouldn't we take the why
should we take the hit on doing the R&D
for a washing machine when we can take
all the profit by selling the tide so
amazon also for things that don't speak
the amazon - service they'll sell you a
button for it so here's a tide button
this is a network computer you can buy
for $5 whose entire purpose is to order
you tide every single time you push the
button it will order you tied and only
tied here you can pass it around
don't be ordering me time i
so so so so you can so if you look here
you can't see so that the top one for
the top one is macit macaroni and cheese
the bottom one is mince these are
services that are effectively preparing
you for infinitely automatically
replenishable macaroni and cheese
it's a macaroni and cheese service that
you will buy into so you never have to
think about buying macaroni and cheese
again the margins on this are insane
so most large case in a most large-scale
inner of things products are service
avatars like this you know they use
specialized sensors and actuators to
support a service but they have very
little value or they don't even work at
all without the supporting service like
it's just like your phone your phone if
you cancel your contract doesn't really
work I mean the Wi-Fi works but you know
theoretically doesn't really work
um when smartthings was acquired by
samsung they clearly state their service
offering up front and tell you very
little about what the stuff does what
the service offers is that they will
help you be home wherever you are they
don't tell you how that's what they're
going to do what is their hardware do
you don't know you don't care you
shouldn't care compare that to x10 their
spiritual predecessor who's been around
since the Tandy color computer all x10
tells you about it's white plastic boxes
is what they are not what they will
accomplish for you like I don't even
know if there is a service why should I
care that they have modules what the
[ __ ] I don't know and I shouldn't I did
that and I don't so I think that the
real value the connected services offer
is their ability to make sense of the
world on our behalf to reduce cognitive
load by enabling people to interact with
the world with devices and a higher
level than simple data than simple
telemetry at the level of intentions and
goals rather than data and control
humans are not built to make sense of
huge amounts of data across many devices
or to articulate our needs as systems of
mutually interdependent
opponents computers have grated all that
[ __ ] now they do this through processes
that have many names but I'm gonna lump
them all under machine learning which is
kind of a big part of what used to be
called artificial intelligence those of
you who are actually in AI will go well
you know there's all these of it
whatever machine learning so many of the
core ideas here actually go back to the
1950s and it's the basis of every spam
filter you ever experience so if you had
your mail automatically spam filter that
you've experienced machine learning a
big part of machine learning is pattern
recognition so we humans evolved very
very sophisticated facilities to rapidly
identify visual images in all kinds of
difficult conditions so you look at a so
today you look at a picture of an orange
on a red plate and you can tell
instantly that it's not a sunset but
until very recently that was incredibly
hard for a computer to do because of a
combination of Moore's law and some
breakthroughs some other breakthroughs
computers have gotten actually much
better at pattern recognition in the
last couple of years
so let me will actually walk you through
a little bit about how this kind of
pattern recognition works so for
computer recognizing something starts
with a process with were some basic
attributes of an imager extracted stuff
which is like the shape of boundaries
between clusters of pixels or the
dominant color of a patch of an image so
these are called features in which in
machine learning speak by examining lots
and lots of examples of features across
many many different images a machine
learning system builds a statistical
model of what those features mean what
they represent you know basic so basic
forms of this kind of a computer vision
have been used industrially for decades
you know when you buy an industrially
grown orange from central California
every single orange that you buy has
been photographed 360 times one degree a
one per degree in order to identify
oranges that have a patches on them
oranges that have blemishes on them and
send the ones that do to Cal feed
instead of to the supermarket every
single freaking orange it's been around
for a really long time Lego has a
completely automated Factory
that molds of million Lego bricks an
hour not a human being in the thing it's
all robots a million bricks an hour they
examine every single brick from a bunch
of different angles discard the ones
that don't work automatically sort the
rest in a bag and they box them all all
using computer vision robots a million
bricks are now are not a human being
steps in that factory that is actually
relatively old technology what's new is
a class of systems that understand the
content of images so they don't just
look at features but clusters of
features and clusters and clusters of
features and now and they can now not
just identify an orange but an orange a
differentiated from the Setting Sun they
can differentiate a person from an
airplane or a polar bear from a
Dalmatian and if you can see that right
there it's very important to do that so
which one do you want as a pet so this
is why Facebook asks you to say who's in
an image it's not for you it's for their
face recognizer now here's the
interesting part
we're built to identify interesting
visual phenomenon we're really bad at
identifying patterns in other kinds of
situations for example if you've ever
tried to understand someone's food
sensitivities it's really hard to
extract what that person is reacting to
even if you care and keep very very
careful track of what they've eaten well
just that build for it it was never an
evolutionarily it was never
evolutionarily sufficiently important
for us to evolve an organ to do that
computers on the other hand don't care
they don't care and now that we found a
really good way is to find patterns in
visual images these same techniques can
find patterns and everything so instead
of a matrix of pixels like you have an
image what if you had a matrix of
medical prescriptions with each row as
the history of one person's prescription
from the first time they went to the
doctor for a problem through when they
were prescribed different things to when
they got better or they didn't the same
kind of pattern recognizing system could
see a typical pattern for prescribing a
certain thing say wheelchair
it would essentially see the general
shape of all the different ways that
people get that wheelchair prescribed
across time across people and then if
you saw a wheelchair being prescribed
there was outside of that typical
pattern you know you can imagine maybe
like a hair if it was a visual image
kind of sticking out um you can identify
it that's what's called anomaly
detection and that's in fact exactly how
people had parked built a system for
Medicare in California to identify
Medicare fraud people are terrible at
that stuff
computers are great at it when one of
the dimensions men becomes a time and
another becomes an outcome of a series
of actions you can then make a pattern
recognizer that associates a sequence of
things that people do with it's a set of
statistical probabilities for possible
outcomes collected across a wide variety
of people on a wide variety of
situations in other words because people
and machines behave in fairly consistent
ways machine learning systems can
increasingly predict the future an
attempt to adapt the current situation
to create a more desirable outcome based
on it so the interesting thing is this
is this is not Theory prediction and
response is at the heart of the value
proposition of many of the most
compelling IOT services starting with
the nest the nest says that it knows you
how does it know you it predicts what
you're going to want based on your
behavior Amazon echo speaker says it's
continuously learning what's it learning
it's learning what you want when you
want it and how you want it
birdie learns Jaguars intelligent car
learns even plant watering system adapts
to every change it learns canary
home-security learns cocoon home
security it knows you
here's fubá and air quality service
recognizes what's she learning actually
my my favorite thing here is also that
it they implicitly say that they will
recognize your kids smoking pot
like oh you know it's learning my
friends silks silks intelligent camera
adapts its learning mist box so miss fox
sprays water into your air conditioner
in order to reduce your energy bill
through evaporative cooling you think
that's a pretty simple process
no it's learning um so a number of
companies are making chips that make
machine learning much cheaper and much
more power efficient which means there's
actually going to be very easy to
install it in virtually every device
from street lights to medical equipment
to toys it's not just like that this
will happen it's inevitable here's a
Qualcomm announcing that this thing from
last week so literally there are
coprocessors they're going to be machine
learning coprocessors they're going to
be in your phone next year if they're
not on your phone this year and you
don't know it they just haven't turned
it on so it's getting pretty big here
this is a smart all it's a Kickstarter
so it doesn't exist so this is a this is
a smart all AI Butler so it's the more
it learns the smarter get what is it I
don't know but there but it's learning
they're doing it so the the ideal
scenario that these things paint is
actually really seductive it's actually
really amazing to think about a world of
espresso machines that start brewing
just as you're thinking that's about a
it's a good time for coffee because you
know you kind of get that coffee every
single at the same time every day
you know off its lights the dim when
it's sunny outside because you know they
can save energy that way and they know
that you're ok with it
mac and cheese it never runs out
the problem is that although the value
proposition is of a better user
experience
they're very unspecific in the details
previous machine learning systems like I
said these things are decades old have
been used in areas such as prevent such
as predictive maintenance aircraft parts
you know it takes well it's really
expensive to take an aircraft down to
change stuff so you're gonna predict
when that thing's gonna fail so you can
change in advanced finance but they were
made by enforced specialists now that
these systems are so cheap and they're
in available for consumers we're we've
got some big questions now how exactly
will our experience of the world our
ability to see all this collected data
become more efficient and more
pleasurable more interesting more
valuable we're still in the very early
days but I want to start by kind of
articulating a couple of issues and then
talking about kind of the implications
of this so um
issue one we've never had mechanical
things that make significant decisions
on their own you know as devices adapt
their behavior how would I communicate
that they're doing that you do we stick
a sign in them that says adapting like
the light on a video camera says
recording you know should my chair
vibrate when it's adjusting to me you
know how will how well people or or just
passers-by hope our users are just
passers-by know which things adapt you
know I could end up sitting for a really
really long time waiting for my chair to
change before I realize it's a dumb
chair you know um how should smart
devices set the expectations that they
me behave differently and what appear to
be identical circumstances how do we
know how on intelligent devices these
devices are you know people already
project way more smarts on devices than
those devices already have you know
think of Roombas right people give them
names so a couple of accurate
predictions may actually imply a much
much more better more sophisticated
model than actually exist how do we know
we're you know how do we know we're not
going really deep and homesteading the
uncanny valley kind of like
going in where everything looks for a
normal but it's super weird
so the irony in these systems is that
the irony and predictive systems is that
they're actually unpredictable at least
at first when machine learning systems
are new they're often inaccurate which
is actually not what we expect from our
things you know 60 or 70 percent
accuracy is actually really good for a
first pass so a machine learning system
but even ninety percent accuracy isn't
enough to make a prediction of
predictive system feel right because
it's making decisions all the time now
it's gonna be making mistakes all the
time it's fine if your house is a couple
of degrees cooler than you'd like or
warmer or whatever but if your
wheelchair refuses to go to a drinking
fountain that's next to a door because
it's been trained on doors and it can't
tell that what you're saying is I want
to go to that thing next to the door not
to the door that's a real problem you
know for and for all the times the
system gets things right you judge it on
its mistakes and mistakes create anxiety
and anxiety is an incredibly heavy kind
of cognitive load to bear and a little
doubt about whether a supposedly smart
system is going to do the right thing is
enough to turn a user experience that's
right most of the time into one that's
more trouble than it's worth the last
issue comes as a result of these
previous two control how do we maintain
some level of control over these devices
when their behaviors by definition
statistical and unpredictable on the one
hand you know you can mangle your
devices predictive behavior by giving it
too much data one I've visited nest one
time in their in their early days and
they told me that none of the nests in
their office actually worked because
they were constantly fiddling with them
they're kind of costly like playing
around it and in machine learning this
is what's called overtraining on the
other hand if I have no direct way to
control it other than through my own
behavior how do I adjust it you know so
Amazon and Netflix is recommendation
systems which are machine learning
systems for predicting what you might
like they've been around for a long time
they give you some context about why
they recommend recommended something why
they're doing something but what if my
only interface is a garden hose what do
I do
how do I get it to stop spraying water
as interesting as these issues are I
actually think that most importantly
what they represent is that we're
entering into a new relationship with
our device ecosystem we're experiencing
a sea change in our relationship to the
bill world so think of a sewing machine
it's really complex but it basically
acts in response to us computers acting
autonomously erode this simple tool user
relationship at the dawn of computing
the late 1940s cyberneticist like Norma
Weiner Norbert Wiener philosophized
about this increasingly complex
relationship between people and
computers and how it was fundamentally
different than the way that we've
interacted with other kinds of machines
and other kinds of tools so developers
who are working in supervisory control
of machine of manufacturing machines so
basically you know things that build
cars things that are the giant robots
and factories they've actually been
having to deal with this with these
questions very pragmatically for a very
long time now thanks to the amount of
things it's an extra everybody's problem
so this this is a diagram by by the
grades Tom Sheridan was a really
brilliant engineer and Bill Verplank
this is from 1978 in which what they're
trying to do is they're trying to
illustrate for ways that semi autonomous
computers and humans can work together
to solve a problem this actually comes
out of an amazing project when they were
in the freakin 70s they were doing these
like semi autonomous submersible robots
that would like go deep underwater and
you they're so deep under water that
you'd have to control them from the
surface but you didn't have like really
great control you just have to tell them
what to do and they don't like 1975 they
were doing this Sheridan continued to
think about this because it's a smart
guy by 2000 he'd actually expanded that
idea to create this framework and to
define a spectrum of responsibilities
between people and computers so it
ranges from the top number one so I'll
read it for the folks in back the the
computer offers no assistance
humans must make all decisions and
actions so it ranges from one where
humans do all the work that's like you
know you writing an essay unless you're
in school in which case you google for
it or you knitting
to ten computers doing all the work the
computer decides everything and acts on
Thomas Lee ignoring the human that is
your car's fuel injection controller so
of course the goal is to get you know
something now down here near nine or ten
you know that's kind of des maximum
reduction on cognitive load but it's for
a system to qualify for that it needs to
be very stable its effects its effects
need to be very predictable and more
importantly its role needs to be very
well embedded and understood in society
we trust it to do that thing at the
airport we trust the monorail computer
to work without a huge without human
intervention but we don't trust the
plane autopilot to do that even though
as I understand it planes can basically
find themselves these days it's not
socially embedded yet predictive IOT
devices generally fall between five and
seven today and probably for the near
future the problem is is that this is
the exact range where you're maximizing
someone's cognitive load because you're
making them make a lot of decisions but
not necessarily doing all the work for
them so the result of the automation had
really better be worth it in order for
that system to work moreover that
relationship fundamentally undermines
what we expect from our tools because
when that tool is trying to anticipate
what we're trying to do and try to get
in front of us and doing it it
fundamentally changes our working
relationship with it
Danny Hillis of the law now talks about
how in an essay they wrote a couple
months ago talks about how we've gone
essentially past the Enlightenment idea
where we thought that we could
understand and control everything and
we've built tools and you know we built
tools in the Enlightenment era that
reflected that view
in his perspective we're actually no
longer in control as much as we are
entangled that's his term entangled with
them and Galloway who's a New Zealand
researcher that looks at the
intersection of animals and digital
technology calls it the end of human
exceptionalism others would say that
it's actually just the postmodern
condition
you know the recognition that the
complexity of the world is beyond our
ability to understand and control and we
have to learn to coax and coexist rather
than a command and control because
sooner than we expect we're gonna be
living with hundreds of devices and
services trying to model us and predict
what's good for us and most of them are
gonna require our attention they're
gonna want us to verify things they're
all gonna want us to upload things
they're gonna want us to confirm things
they're gonna want us to validate their
existence and they're gonna be wrong a
lot and they're gonna be annoying if
because if you have a hundred devices
and each device is 99% accurate and
that's really good for a prediction for
a particular algorithm one device is
always wrong so how do we engage with
this world how do we approach wrangling
all of these different tools together
because we're gonna have a lot of them
well you can think about working
surrounded by a bunch of apprentice
assistants as in a middle aged guild or
you can think or you can take an animist
view and assume that everything in the
world has a consciousness Phil Van Alen
of the Art Center College of Design
recently actually started at advocating
exactly this approach that we start
thinking of everything in Animus terms
then we start making Animus devices um
you know maybe not like this but I like
to explore it a different approach I
like to explore farming as a metaphor I
like metaphors in terms of interaction
design so I'd like to explore farming as
a metaphor and I just because of that
this superficial irony of using a
pre-enlightenment technology to talk
about a post-enlightenment problem right
ok yeah whoo
I really want to create a useful way of
thinking about the challenge of smart
tools so that we can design a better
relationship with them from the
beginning because we're at the beginning
of this thing farming is one of our
oldest technologies it's one of our most
advanced and there's one of the ones
that's been the most brutal on the land
the people and the animals involved but
it got us here without it we'd still be
like you know that kind of trees I I
don't know savanna so so I think it's a
it's a it's a good metaphor also let me
make it aside to make an admission so
I'm a city kid
my family's been living in cities going
back generations
I have not raised so much as a single
edible plant or owned a pet
I have children but I don't think it's
the same thing the long now asked me to
do something brand new and this is where
I ended up so if this stock hasn't
already gone off the rails for you it
probably will now so uh for me farming
is a useful metaphor about how to
simultaneously manipulate the state of
many autonomous independent similar
things for your personal game a farmer
doesn't raise an ear of corn she raises
a field of corn and she's not a in
control of her crops as much as she is
in symbiosis with them to some extent
she reduces the complexity of the
farming process by planting many copies
of the same plant and dividing her land
into regions for each different kind of
plant right now if you think about the
Internet of Things it's like each thing
that you're looking at is totally
different and requires a totally
different technique to work with every
single thing is different every single
and you have to think about every single
thing independently that is not how
farming works moreover a farmer selects
crops that thrive in a specific set of
conditions and which can you know
broadly speaking synergistically used
the same raw material to maximize the
value of that material in the land so
what if we had multiple algorithms that
used information from the same
what if we had multiple things that
we're looking at the output from all the
cameras and all the temperature sensors
and all of the various other things in
the environment but we're doing
different things with them they were
treating them as different raw material
you know wouldn't that be like a useful
way of dealing with a lot of stuff so
farmer uses specialized tools to make it
to work on many plants at the same time
you know whether it's a plow or it's a
harvester or it's a scarecrow right this
is why she chooses many of the same
things right because she can then use a
single tool to you to work on all of
them so in the algorithm analogy how can
we group large numbers of algorithms
large numbers of things and services and
work on them all at once she also
expects pests right now everyone is
shocked when their smart fridge starts
posting spam because it's been hacked
it's kind of like a fungus infection
right you know farmers have tools for
that kind of thing they try to maintain
good practices to avoid it but when it
happens no one is surprised and they
kind of know that this is the kind of
thing that they have to deal with so a
farmer also doesn't expect to extract
value from the thing immediately you
know it may take months or years
everything you know if you have an
orchard if she knows that she'll have to
maintain it that whole time she's got to
take care of it even though it's not
providing value for her right now we
expect our digital products to work
immediately or we think that they're not
worthwhile what do we think they're
defective what if we designed things so
they would be only be useful after we
had lived with them for a really long
time but then it'd be really useful what
that look like I'm not sure I know so
another aside let me talk a little bit
give you another term so machine
learning algorithms are pattern
recognizers and so they need to know
which patterns are important whenever
you mark the email a spam you're in your
email program you're using what's called
training you are training the algorithm
to understand what you consider spam
similarly when you are making a choice
using word
virtually any digital device or service
you're training it
Facebook's asked you to label people in
the picture to train its algorithms to
associate a set of facial features with
the personal you labeled and of course
with the other people who you've also
labeled and the people that they know
and the things that they're doing and
the places they've they are and when
they're doing it and how they're doing
it so what happens when you train a
single animal what are your mechanisms
of control what are your expectations
while you accept that it's gonna require
time and it will require a combination
of both positive and negative
reinforcement then you expect that that
thing will regularly misbehave you're
gonna have to reinforce what you teach
it conversely you can expect they will
probably learn a bit from other animals
without you having to tell everything
and its behavior will surprise you in
good ways and in bad ways what happens
when you a farmer has a lot of animals
to control she can't train all of them
you know she can't train all of them
individually so over the last you know
say 10,000 years she's developed some
tools first she selects and animals that
work well in groups so our algorithms
are currently built one at a time and
the expectation is that our interaction
were with them will be individual that
isn't scale we need algorithms that are
experienced well together or else we're
not hurting sheep we're herding cats
next she has a crook well she's a
shepherd oh when you need to assert
control you need a clear way to do that
which works on a wide variety of animals
and and which works immediately we need
consistent ways to assert immediate
control over a wide variety of smart
devices we don't have that she has a dog
which is kind of a smarter entity it's
smarter than the other entities but it's
you know it's still not quite where she
is um it also needs to be trained but
once it's trained he can actually
autonomously control some of the other
things
she can hand off she can also hand off
the work to an assistant in farming
there are whole classes of people who
work together who collaborate and who
share responsibility and delegate
responsibility for different kinds of
activities that they do with a single
set of entities fluffy fluffy entities
um as Tom coats of thinking points out
today most IOT systems are actually not
built for many people to control them
simultaneously even though their effects
are often experienced in shared
environments effectively what we have
today is not an internet of things we
have an AOL of we have many AOL's of
things we have a menagerie of things not
a herd you know they've intentionally
been made mutually incompatible and some
of them are really cute on their own but
when you have a lot of them and you have
to deal with all of them individually
and all of them have to be dealt with
differently you've got a big problem so
I think in a thousand years maybe a
hundred years this entire discussion is
gonna seem absurd it's not gonna be a
it's like we're gonna be arguing about
whether iron is a good thing or a bad
thing you know we'll see it is just the
way the world is um we're gonna see our
bodies ourselves as kind of semi
autonomous components that we have some
control over in an ecosystem that
combines both other biological
semi-autonomous components into digital
semi autonomous components everything is
going to have some control over other
things and to be controlled by other
things some of these things are going to
be smarter than others some of them are
gonna be more autonomous on there than
others some are gonna be smarter than us
in certain ways we're gonna be smarter
than some of them in certainly some are
gonna have positive symbiotic
relationships with us some are going to
be parasites the boundary is between our
minds and our bodies between the natural
and artificial between the human and
non-human will
really been eroded our world will have
reconfigured itself around the
assumption that everything is a lot more
permeable and much less clearly
delineated then we've been fooling
ourselves since the start of the
Enlightenment into believing because we
are not as gods we are and always have
been animals in an ecosystem and what
would all be good there'll probably be
terrible things that happen to people's
bodies and their minds and their
societies they're also hopefully be good
things but regardless this is the
looking glass that we've made for
ourselves and we have and it's time for
us to step through it and explore the
field beyond because we have no choice
but to engage with it to make it be what
we want it to be what we need it to be
because it is not androids that are
gonna be dreaming of electric sheep
it's gonna be us
[Applause]
alright alright that thank you Mike
those fantastic um so we're good we got
time for a few questions real quick
though a quick shout out to our folks
that are listening on the livestream I
hope some of you may may be able to send
questions through and to Edward
Burtynsky and his new project the
Anthropocene because they're sponsoring
our live streams all year long so I'm
gonna steal the first question we've got
a microphone floating around for you
folks to go back so you mentioned I'm
forgetting exactly what you said you
said me too but you you you mentioned
that some of the things that we have
less tools than useless things I figured
what word to use for useless things but
I noticed the word that you use for
useless things was not toys or games
gadgets or it was but it was but the
point was that there there there are
things that we can't do anything with
there are things that aren't there not
actual tools what about play what about
things that because in the history of
the web and other innovations that's
engaging with that as advanced things a
lot what do you thought some things that
promise efficiency play is not a good
end stick that are intended as toys or
as games or as entertainment efficiency
is not that important and if they don't
promise that that's what they're doing
it's great to have the opportunity to
play and play can be you know any number
of things you know it can be literally
like a toy or it can be you know for
some for somebody writing software oh
but if what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to like accomplish a thing that
it's saying that it's going to do for me
making me do that the that is actually
making it worse than useless for me but
but as far as do you see things that are
out there that are I don't know where
there's augmented reality kinds of
things are starting to engage that same
kind of framework or toys are one of the
first places that are that a lot of
technology there's really a lot of like
physical
technology has really tested out in just
as like in media porn tests out all the
technology first in kind of uh kind of
like consumer robotics as toys so you
know if you if you think about like a
tickle-me-elmo extreme which has been
around for about ten years that's part
of the product name is extreme so it's a
robot it's a robot that's a that's a red
fluffy toy robot that has all these
behaviors right now they don't do
machine learning but they can they will
they will do it for you
like that's essentially what the Furby
was simulating that's what the polio
dinosaur was simulating now that's gonna
be a part of everyday toys they're
actually literally going to learn
instead of simply simular so I think
that that's definitely gonna be part of
it and it's gonna be fun it's gonna be
it's gonna be great and the you know
unpredictability in a thing that you
think is kind of like somewhere between
a pet and a game is great
unpredictability in a thing that you
think is you're using to accomplish a
task not great yeah yeah alright do we
have that there we go first question
yeah it should be just a hold it really
close here there we go so so if we're
farming algorithms right now I think
we're getting our seed from Monsanto
we've got you know we we're not in
control we're actually getting our
actual seed for Monsanto also just
remember that but but you know right now
you know the reason I don't have an
Amazon echo is because I don't really
want Amazon listening to everything I
say in my house we do how do you we as
consumers you know get control over all
these smart things that are going to be
in our house watching us I think that's
a very challenging question I think the
important thing is to understand
something about what the end of they're
doing and how they're doing it and then
right now to not lock yourself too into
them and all
so to delete your history often so like
I use Google's mapping technology I
delete my location history once a month
I use Waze I don't have an account on it
I use I use Facebook I've turned off a
lot of the stuff on on that to the
extent that I can so I use Twitter and
I'm assuming that someone's data-mining
me and so part of it is is just kind of
selectively choosing which things you
often - based on how much value they
give you and another another part is
also understanding that I think for the
most part they're not malicious so they
don't mean to make things bad and they
will make mistakes they don't mean to
make things bad and so you have to treat
them as mostly but it's like having a
puppy right it's like they're mostly
benign and so there'll be my credit
history again that's all it did that's
good it's got another end that can also
do something like creative history
anyway so that's that that's my personal
answer I I think that's a I think it's a
really I think it's a conversation that
we have with technology every single day
and that we should just continue to have
not be afraid of it just remember to
have a conversation so thanks for your
talk I'm not quite sure after hearing
what you say whether or not you are a
believer or a advocate for general
purpose learner which is you know
obviously highly debated contest between
machine learners machine learning you
believe in it no cherrylle purpose
learner mean oh oh from A to B you can
find whatever algorithm is actually best
so do you are you asking whether I'm a
hard a I proponent would that I believe
that there's going to be a general
purpose of mind that is equivalent
a kind of cognition or no not exactly
what you say before was we live in a
world of menagerie of algorithms where
there's no connections and there's no
crew and therefore right the task of
selecting which algorithms to pair with
could be left off to a an algorithm by
itself which could actually be yeah
another time machine right so if there
is such an hour of them then that will
be a general purpose learner right
not necessarily it can be very special
specialized to your house it can be
specialized to the api's that the
various devices speak and it can be
essentially one that does automatically
the kind of things that I do to
anonymize things or to kind of tailor
the data to be the training data to be
more in line with my values to be more
in line with my with my interest it
doesn't have to be something that's
simulating me yeah so this is to
advocate for human to be the supervisor
of that process yes yeah what that looks
like I don't know so so if you there's a
book called the master algorithm that is
by Pedro so he goes to me good yeah so
he talks about that so he's essentially
says like we're gonna need a master
algorithm I don't like the metaphor of a
master algorithm I like the metaphor of
a dog algorithm you know I think it's
has the power structure correctly but
but I think that there is gonna be an
opportunity there what that thing looks
like I don't know I I think I think we
need to be able to I don't think that
all the various companies that are
making all the animals and the menagerie
are actually ever going to get together
and make a sheep that's just not going
to happen eventually one of them will
eat the others and will have like a
bunch of rhinos and then we're just
gonna have to be Rhino farming but until
until that happens week
we're gonna have something that is going
to be you know hopefully we can make
something that can help us manage the
rest Mike how are things advancing right
now between academic research private
research like you go that and and
startups versus big corporations what's
sort of the ecosystem of the innovation
right now would you say the ecosystem of
the innovation is that academic
departments to get really good at this
get bought by Google and and then or by
Amazon or or Apple or hopefully not
Palantir so I mean I think we do a lot
of it as a essentially independent
research lab and so the way the park
works and just to give you some a little
bit of tiny bit of insight so we're a
wholly owned by Xerox but we don't just
do research for Xerox like I said you
can hire us you can hire Park we do a
lot of machine learning we do a lot of
internet of things stuff we have with
some three clients we have Xerox we have
the US government specifically
specifically government grants from
DARPA and arpa-e and places like that
and we have private companies we work
basically and by private companies I
mean generally a fortune 100 companies
so those are our three classes of
clients and we're doing work for all of
them all the time in machine learning so
like you know we did work for the state
of California and there aren't that many
places that that work the way that we
work but I think that that's but I think
that there are a lot of things that are
very rapidly coming up from academia and
then they get very rapidly
commercialized and I mean basically any
graduate student that has a PhD in
something resembles machine learning
gets snapped up by you know Facebook
Amazon Apple you know what Brewster
calls the stacks right you know one of
five companies and they're the ones that
are there the big they're the they're
the charismatic medical megafauna in my
right right right so so we'll take one
more questions like I want to ask you a
question we don't have your book here
tonight but tell us for a second what is
your book I know your book it's used as
a textbook and a lot of these programs
and and also maybe just a quick couple
reading lists if that you recommend if
folks want to follow up with more to
learn more than I and so I think I think
I should actually like tweet out the
reading let's say I have little kids I
don't read anything anymore we can do
that yeah
tell us about your book so observing the
user experience is a series of centra
it's a cookbook for methods to
understand how people experience
technological products the second
edition was revised by my brilliant
lovely wife who rewrote most of it
because I you know she's smarter than me
a lot and so smart things is now
slightly dated I have to say it's a I
still think a lot of it is relevant
because I wrote it but it's it's
essentially about kind of the kind of
conceptual infrastructure of the talk
that I gave like this specific thing
isn't going to be in there because the
book is six years old but a lot of the
ideas that that framed this are
definitely in it and again Alyssa's
designing connected products book from
O'Reilly is a great book I happen to see
drafts of it early on and so that's yeah
so so that's a I think a really good
how-to book in terms of thinking about
the implications of this stuff to kind
of the broader idea so the master
algorithm is a pretty good book it came
out last September let me let me think
if I can think of a weekend of Bruce
Sterling's IOT kind of
pamphlet / booklet that he wrote last
year was really good in terms of like
his somewhat critical perspective on
this I think it's a very good critical
perspective so I can make it great we
have one more there we go one last
question there so as we outsource a lot
of our experience with things that we're
gonna be interacting with to these
algorithms how do we manage the loss of
serendipity or the outlier things that
we would actually like but now we're not
seeing because it doesn't really fit the
profile things are regressing to the
mean they're gonna simulate serendipity
for you so that's that's the kind of
like flip answer I mean I think that I
think that's an issue I think that there
is this this this issue of kind of the
Disney Rhoda fication created by these
things where essentially because they
create experiences that are based on the
mean or some variant of the mean because
all of them do kind of make a model of
you to describe like how you are
different than the mean and then they
try to give you your own kind of version
of the mean but they still do
tend to do that um I think I think
that's gonna be such a question for
agency for like what people want to do
with their time and their lives and
that's gonna be I think an opportunity
because I like I said I think you know
I'm of two minds here actually I'm have
one one mind roughly that a lot of
things these things when they work
they're gonna be really useful they're
gonna be really really good
they're gonna make these things that are
really annoying to us not be annoying
you know they're gonna make those
routine shopping trips or like aw crap
it's like 10:30 I'm out of diapers
they're gonna make that go away and and
maybe you love it when you have to do
that a lot of
people don't but but so that that will
theoretically give you more time to
watch Game of Thrones or whatever but
but I think that the the it's gonna be
up to us to uh I mean it's kind of a
non-answer and I'm sorry but like I
think it's gonna be up to us to really
utilize them in ways that they retain
their utility but they don't cross over
into a kind of Blanding out the world
thank you okay before we wrap up we've
got some other parked I think it's gonna
be months in the future probably give us
a little teaser on what some of the
other things you guys are working on
that we may be hearing about okay so I'm
gonna give you two things
we're probably gonna talk a little bit
about printed electronics so we are
currently developing a set of
technologies that fundamentally do away
with the traditional means of making
electronics so the way that electronics
are made right now they're like itched
and silicon and you have all of these
different these different processes that
require giant fab what we're doing is
we're essentially using a conductive and
semi conductive and resistive materials
to print logic to print batteries to
print displays to print sensors to print
actuators using things like inkjet
printers or essentially giant groove
your printers like the kind of year the
newspapers are printed on so what we're
doing is were that you're recreating the
way electronics are made in these ways
that are incredibly cheap and incredibly
of and actually because we use a lot of
like kind of organic semiconductor
materials there she's like roughly
speaking better for the world although
it's still xtronic and I think that
actually really interesting like they're
now allowing us to do things like wrap
an airplane in a giant sensor grid
that's a giant sticker and so that's
pretty cool
and I think I saw that at Burning Man
though so not that airplane and not that
air and also we're doing a lot of really
interesting stuff around health
analytics around essentially utilizing
what it's called the data exhaust that
happens in the in the data world where a
lot of stuff happens in a hospital a lot
of people are kind of taking a lot of a
lot of data a lot of data down but they
never have any time to correlate that
data across a bunch of different things
to understand symptoms and cures for
things that may be non-obvious
unless you look at this enormous set of
data all at once so we're working on
that stuff that's pretty cool cool and
actually Alexander Rose our executive
director is going to be speaking down a
park at the end of next month
so we'll be go we'll be tweeting about
that so well so thanks yeah
so Mike thank you this is a long now
challenge Quinn to thank you for your
fantastic talk was that a good it's not
smart it's dumb
[Applause]
[Music]
you